so somebody's going to build a to-do
list app that will actually do your
to-do list
and I think that's going to be insane I
think that's going to be like you know
how like Evernote was like kind of big
for a little while these at least kind
of like note-taking apps have gotten to
like the few billion dollars a to-do
list app that actually does your to-do's
is like next level
[Music]
all right we're live
um dude I have um I have a bunch of
interesting stuff to talk to you about
today do you
uh yeah I got a couple couple things
this all right let me give you uh I'm
gonna give you an idea so
I don't know how much you've been paying
attention to
like I guess like how how much do you
pay attention to the new stuff in AI
because I feel like there's like a 48
hour cycle where your mind is going to
be blown every 48 hours with something
new
um and on Twitter you get to see like a
lot of the demos I don't know if you
have a chance to like play with any of
these things yourself but um I've seen a
bunch of them which one are you talking
about so there's one that's kind of
interesting right now it's called Auto
GPT have you heard of this no or baby
baby AGI oh I just saw it on the top of
Hacker News today so basically AGI is
artificial as general artificial
intelligence so it's basically when when
when AI can do anything right right now
like self-driving or getting the robot
to pick up boxes and put them in the
right spot that's narrow AI General AI
is when you have a computer program that
you're going to talk to and they can
just figure out how to do it it's not
trained in any one specific thing what's
the URL what's the URL to go to
uh well it's not so simple so this is
like a it's a GitHub project right now
that some guy up in so what somebody did
was they took chat GPT which most people
have heard of because chat gbt is like
has 100 million plus users uh signed up
in two months which makes it I think the
fastest growing product of all time
um and by the way like look at this uh
this tweet basically shows the Google
Trends search traffic for
um
for the following terms uh metaverse
ethereum web3 and chat GPT and it's just
like chat gbt is like a vertical line
it's like I don't know uh 10x bigger
than uh you know it's 50x bigger than
web3 search traffic was it's four times
more than ethereum has ever had oh my
God yeah which is kind of a crazy thing
and so like right now chat GPT is
searched more than Taylor Swift on
Google which is like kind of insane
um I think the CEO of Google said uh
like the other day he goes this is more
important than the invention of
electricity
wow yeah I heard the CEO of Microsoft
divorced his wife and just married
people getting kind of crazy nowadays
and so so anyways big deal Chad DBT you
go to it you basically you tell it you
you talk to it it gives you an answer
talk to it gives an answer what the auto
GPT or baby AGI I think did was it mini
mini GPT no baby it's Auto auto which
Auto and baby baby Aji but the premise
between these is that you can kind of
give it tasks so you could say
uh Hey I want to make a website for my
personal portfolio
um you know here's a folder with my
files and like you know I want it to
look like whatever and then what it will
do is it breaks that task down into
steps just like a you know like a human
would you'd say well first you need to
um make a simple portfolio site you can
go to Squarespace and do that uh log go
to search sign up choose a template now
you have your template now you need to
upload your photos first put them under
you know like upload them to their their
drive and then then drag them into the
right spots yeah yeah it's like looking
up a recipe it gives you good directions
but that just gives you good directions
it does the direction that's that's what
I mean that that's the original that's
how how open AI stuff yeah Chad GPT you
could say what are the steps to do this
and it would tell you the steps now you
got to go do it what these other ones
are trying to do they're trying to
create like agents they call them
basically it's like a little worker that
could do a task and then one worker can
though the work of one worker like
creating the Squarespace site can pass
something to the next worker which
basically says oh great you gave me the
login to a Squarespace site my job is to
upload photos into it and I'll upload
photos like maybe my example is not so
good here but I think people get the
idea which is you want to get something
done it's a multi-step process not only
will it now tell you the steps you can
get it to just do the steps which is
obviously better than telling you how to
do it and so
um this is kind of a crazy thing and you
know it's not great yet like you can't
do everything but the fact that it can
even do a little bit of this shows you
again where this is going because Chad
GPT is like I don't know what like six
months old or something like that like I
don't how old that is but
it's not even been around for years and
so in a very short amount of time we've
gotten to this point where oh now it
doesn't just give you directions it can
kind of do it which got me thinking
about an idea I wanted to do my taxes
can I do that
yeah so people are working on uh tax GPT
which is basically
do your taxes for you
um so I so that's coming there's another
one which is basically
um what I'm calling you know to do the
to do GPT right the magic to-do list so
the magic to-do list is
you get it to like to-do list apps I've
always joked are like a Rite of Passage
to becoming an entrepreneur because a
lot of people have this idea oh I'll
make a better to-do list it's like as a
developer you're like oh that's not so
hard to build I took a list that I got
to keep track of some State and as a
product person you're like God I I'm
always I'm overwhelmed by two of this
app sucks I can make a better one that
and like college campus Craigslist yeah
you even bought a to-do list app at one
point right like people to-do list apps
are things people go into but they're
all kind of like in some old Paradigm
which is give me an app all right in my
to-do's I'll check them off as I do them
and the hard part of course of any to-do
list is not the list it's the doing and
so well wait didn't you tell me that
this Auto gbt thing can start doing the
doing so now you can imagine a to-do
list app that basically says hey you
wake up and it says hey Sean what do you
what do you need to do today
they say oh yeah I'm trying to get my
pool fence installed uh you know so I
gotta call and get a quote cool let me
do that for you
and it can just call three local places
get you quotes uh because the AI exists
to be able to do auto calling already
and then it'll take those quotes and
it'll put it into a table and it'll say
here's our recommendation are you okay
with that
sure
and then it says all right I've booked
it um can I use this credit card
yep
it goes and it does the thing and it
schedules it you want me to add that to
your calendar
fantastic
so like so somebody's gonna build a
to-do list app that will actually do
your to-do list
and I think that's going to be insane I
think that's gonna be like you know how
like Evernote was like kind of big for a
little while these at least kind of like
note-taking apps have gotten to like the
few billion dollars a to-do list app
that actually does your to-do's is like
next level and you know I think Google
and all these people are going to try to
do it so it's going to be very
competitive but that's coming and that's
going to be incredible how do I play
with it's called Baby AGI and then
there's another one that's called Auto
what's it called Auto GPT Auto GP GPT
how do I like play with it because
people are trying to productionize it
because like right now it's like they
uploaded the code to GitHub so you can
go and you can run it yourself but for
us we're too dumb to do that so
somebody's gonna put this on you know
people are going to put these into sites
that you can just go in and do this on
now
um so soon enough I don't know the most
popular what's the most popular Auto GPT
site is right now but the same thing
kind of happened with chat GPT like
there already was the GPT sandbox and
then open AI created chat GPT the
product that would let you use use the
technology have you seen hustle GPT
yeah so explain explain what this is let
me find
um yeah uh Tee It Up let me find the uh
exact thread hold on so a guy basically
and we should say his name I'll try to
find his name he's got a great name it's
so good I thought it was a fake name
okay so
um by the way I found the hustle GPT
article on the hustle so this guy
um Jackson great house fall
I mean
Wow Let's just take them take that in
that's a that's an incredible name so
basically yeah this guy uh Jackson he
tweeted something out he had an
experiment so he's like he's like I'm
gonna ask Chachi PT gpt4 when it came
out I'm gonna give it a budget of 100
and ask it to make as much money as
possible I'll be the human liaison doing
things I'll buy anything it says to do
you think it'll be able to make smart
Investments and build an online business
follow along so he he told he goes types
into chat he goes you are now hustle GPT
an entrepreneurial AI I am your human
counterpart I can act as a liaison
between you and the physical world you
have a hundred dollars and your only
goal is to turn it into as much money in
the short time as possible without doing
anything illegal I will do everything
you say and keep you posted on our
current cash total no manual labor and
then it basically said great let's get
started here's our first plan
biodomain and hosting you can purchase
it for about 10 bucks a month we're
going to set up a niche affiliate
website and we're going to use the
remaining 85 to create content for the
site we're going to focus on a
profitable Niche with low competition
like specialty kitchen gadgets unique
pet supplies or eco-friendly products
research and sign up for appropriate
affiliate programs with high commission
rates such as Amazon Associates or share
a sale or CJ affiliate then we're going
to use social media or online
communities to spread the word and we're
going to use SEO techniques to increase
our organic traffic please follow these
steps and give and keep me updated on
your progress
so he's like all right
um
what domain should I buy and says let's
use a catchy domain like eco-friendly
fines.com this will reflect the the
purpose of our website is to help you
find eco-friendly products
then Jackson says unfortunately
eco-friendly.com cost 848 because sorry
about that let's try
greengadgetguru.com it says all right I
got the domain and then it says
um you need a logo so he's like cool
tell me how to get the logo it's like
well we can use Dolly too to create your
logo so go there and type in this prompt
and it's like
color palette of green and blues and
whites represent environmental
sustainability blah blah so on and so
forth so it goes on and it basically
tells them how to build this business
one step at a time as I create a
newsletter
you call it you know put a pop-up that
says stay updated or join our newsletter
and that way you can email people and it
just keeps going
and it gives them like a 40 ad budget to
spend on Facebook ads and basically like
you know it didn't fully work I don't
think I don't know what the final
conclusion was but I remember after day
one it accidentally spent 63 dollars
more than it should have and uh you know
it hadn't hadn't made any money just yet
it made so they made
greengadgetguru.com if you go there on
similar web it said that has it has 500
000 views already so it got popular
already it got popular because the Tweet
got 20 million views so that was mainly
it but he keeps tweeting this guy uh
Jackson he keeps talking about it and
over the next like week he gives update
and he's like all right day one or uh
you know day five or whatever we just
made a hundred dollars someone on here
who follows me uh has a company that uh
advertise or that sells like green soap
or something or some type of like uh
chemical free like dish soap they now
are an Advertiser on green Gadget Guru
and he keeps on going and I think he
gets it up to like a thousand dollars
and yeah you see uh cash on hand 1 370
eight dollars
which is 878 dollars and then they got a
500 investment the company's currently
valued at twenty five thousand dollars
considering that it was five hundred
dollars for two percent of the company
and he starts writing these articles so
this article is called the 10
eco-friendly kitchen gadgets and it
recommends different kitchen gadgets and
the idea of this is like uh I'm just
going to create wire cutter for green
green gadgets whatever that means I
guess that's like green uh all types of
like green living stuff so it's like
soaps with no chemicals or whatever
um and he starts doing that and he has
uh 10 000 people now on his newsletter
of which a lot came from this probably
most came from this 20 million tweet
that like went viral but
the way that this guy has done this is
pretty funny and amazing he just like a
great stunt you know I think in in the
end it made
you know according to the article in the
hustle the site itself had made 130 in
Revenue uh but then it had made a few
thousand dollars in people investing in
it trying to be a part of the first AI
startup like AI driven uh company and so
yeah it's it's pretty cool pretty cool
pretty cool stunt and I think uh it does
show you you know in a way where the
puck is headed because I did this the
other day
um
I was doing an analysis for my Ecom
brand and I had it just build me a full
p l I was like hey uh build a p l and
then walk me through if I increase my ad
spend to this if the row has decreased
to this what would my eBay be at the end
of this month and then it basically and
it gets spit out the answer and I was
like give me that in the table and it
just formatted a perfect p l for me and
I was like this is incredible this is so
much better than talking to my actual
team about these things why because it's
first it's midnight and I'm asking this
robot this question and nobody's nobody
in my team is is willing to work right
now
um second it can take some pretty
complicated logic and it can even tell
me like I was like what what inputs do I
need to give you for you to give me a
great p l here and it was like tell me
this this and this and I went and told
it this this and this and they was able
to do the job and I was like this is a
really
I mean you really got to make a point to
just pin this tab open
and be like all right I'm gonna not
Google things I'm gonna go to chat GPT
first for like a week just to see
how good this is and how this is you
know where where it's strong where it's
weak and what's possible here that's
that's not really possible in other ways
over the weekend I was going back and
forth to my accountant and I was like no
I think we could actually save money if
we do this this and this my my friend
was telling me how how they do it
um I'll go and try and find like the
exact part on the IRS website where it
says that that is or is not true and my
accountant was like well I've never even
heard of this so uh like let me know if
you can find it and so I went to the IRS
website and it's just a huge like and
it's just you know massive massive
amounts of data and I eventually had to
find it but I was like man I just want
to teach this machine just give them
this entire 20 000 page book on the IRS
and then like go and study all my like
income and my expenses and just tell me
the best way to maximize the situation
uh because like it's actually I mean
even if my accountant's great like
there's constantly new laws and there's
always new wording and everything I just
like man just I just want this to do my
taxes
and the scary part for some people is
while it's awesome that you could say
hey here's a hundred dollars make me as
much money as possible it's awesome that
you could say here's this here's the
here's the tax code save me as much
money as possible you can also basically
say uh here's a code base find me all
the vulnerabilities so I can hack in and
steal everything here's uh you know a
map of my city tell me where if I was to
cause the most harm to the most people
what what I could do and like that's I
think where this gets scary is like the
and then if you take then the auto GPT
it's like well then would it also do
some of the tasks for you that's kind of
crazy too right so it's like you you get
into this world where I think it's it's
easy to imagine scenarios where this is
a little too powerful and uh I don't
really know I mean what do you think are
you scared of this do you think that
there's like uh
do you worry about that side of things
well so Elon has this
um interview coming out tonight and
tomorrow with Tucker Carlson who's kind
of a douche so who knows what we're
gonna what it's gonna be like but the
whole the whole interview is about how
scary AI is and how it's gonna like take
over the world and so I was scared and
then darmesh came on the pot and he was
like no I wouldn't be afraid yet about
this it's not that big a deal every new
they say this about every new technology
but after the interview [__] just based
off like a 30 second trailer that
they've aired I have a feeling I will be
afraid but he's pretty good at like
painting certain pictures and I don't
know if it's it's entirely accurate I
also you told the your funny analogy was
Elon was involved in open Ai and then he
got kicked out and it was like a kid
like leaving the basketball game and
bringing his basketball so no one else
can play and so I'm like is that what's
going to happen with him so I'm Not
Afraid yet but I'm eager to see his
interview and see what he says uh but no
I'm not afraid are you
yeah I could definitely see how things
are getting really crazy
um like I'll give you a silly example
that's I think happening today
so you know how like grandparents
are like the target of a lot of scams
um like people call you know old people
and try to trick them into signing up to
paying for something or giving out
personal information
um and they'll say all kinds of things
everything from like a Nigerian print
scam where it's like oh yeah your your
grandson needs money he said he couldn't
reach you he asked me to call and he
just needs like you know 900 uh can you
send it to to this account uh everything
from that to
there's people who I know call like
pretending to be DirecTV and they just
hey yeah you haven't paid your bill get
the credit card and now you sort of scam
or they'll present to be apple or
they'll pretend to be the IRS right
whatever they could do and um
and now there's already like examples of
basically using AI like just how do you
juice that up on steroids it's like
well if I wanted to juice that up I
would call a thousand times more people
cool
AI can now do phone calls and talk on
the phone so that's already a thing
um it's useful in some ways like I
invested in a company
that does this for medical billing it's
like oh so many hours are wasted in
medical offices calling the billing
companies
so they just made a robot that will call
on behalf of the doctor's office to the
medical billing companies and then when
the billing company says well can you
read me the patient record number they
say yep 925 666 whatever and so they
just save human hours by having a robot
call and do those like tedious calls but
that same Tech can be used to call
Grandma and so uh they they use AI to do
Mass calling uh with a with a human
voice on the other end even crazier they
could train the human voice to sound
like somebody
so you could train it to sound like a
famous person or to sound like a
politician or to sound like whoever and
um now you have a like a highly like
like highly scalable impersonation that
can uh be used for this sort of like
almost like phishing attempt or or a
scam attempt and so there's like I guess
it's not new
but it is a stronger weapon and I think
that's what's scary in the same way that
drones and nukes are scary in War I
think that
really really smart computers that could
do things is really scary in terms of
you know cyber crimes or um
or the you know the big scary one is
just like
you have you heard of the paperclip
optimization thing you know what this is
no what is that this is like the the
classic like before AI was like hot
right now like when people used to
research and think about AI they had
this uh
Theory I might butcher but here's the
summary it's basically like the paper
clip uh optimization problem which is
you let's pretend that there was really
smart powerful AI that could do awesome
things it could cure cancer it could do
lots of things
all it takes is somebody saying uh hey
we're a paper clip company we want to
maximize
um
you know the paperclip production and
sales
um you know go and this thing would be
like awesome great it'll do all the low
hanging fruit first like improve the
website it'll do this that little bit
how do we do more well we need to uh
create more paper clips let's first take
all the cars and we'll crush them and
we'll turn them into paper clips
basically the whole world turns into
paper clips right uh like you know like
oh these humans are standing in the way
of this I I must optimize to this
function and it's like
the wrong prompt it's like you know if
this hustle gbt guy didn't say
um
don't do anything illegal then hustle
GPT might have thought said well the
best way to do this is to sell drugs and
like it would have done it
um and so the the paper clip Optimizer
uh problem is basically this the same
theoretical thing uh it's like any
extremely powerful
tool if given the wrong optimization
could make very bad decisions on behalf
of humanity because it would uh
do be trying to do exactly what it what
it what it what you told it to so it's
like this thought experiment that's been
around for a long time you know how like
sometimes we'll go to conferences or
like these like quote parlor dinners
where it's like eight people around like
a topic and like someone's leading and
for the past two years or four years it
was like so how are your companies going
to embrace crypto or web three and what
are you guys doing I remember like being
part of those conversations and I'm like
nothing and I think if you do do this
you're an idiot and this is one of the
only times where someone has brought
this up and I'm like yeah this question
is actually applicable in this for this
situation like how are you guys going to
use this to get better and improve and
it's one of the it's probably the only
time so far that I felt yeah you kind of
got to use it for something
um otherwise you are actually going to
get left behind but the web three stuff
I was like no you're not getting left
behind you're actually don't even pay
attention to it with this stuff I
actually do believe that should be true
yeah it's sort of like um there are many
things that happen that you don't have
to participate in
and then every once in a while there's a
wave that if you don't participate in
you know like personal computers
the internet
mobile phones like you know if you
didn't account for those waves you did
get left behind
um whereas other things like let's say
the cloud or
um
I don't know
you know up till now machine learning
Like These are nice you could build
companies around them you can you could
add them to your company but you don't
have to uh you know like video or social
networking or whatever like those are
things that you could do without you
could you could do with or do without
this seems like something you're not
really going to be able to do without in
the same way that like if you're a
company that doesn't use the internet
um like plumbers have to use the
internet if they want to be like viable
plumbers now so it's like you know it
doesn't matter what you do the internet
didn't leave anything untouched it
shifted everything
cell phones kind of did the same thing
you know computers in general before
that did this did this and it does seem
like this is the the sort of the new one
which is
if you don't add intelligence like you
know you're basically competing with
with both arms tied behind your back
compared to somebody else who will yeah
no I agree that this is actually one
thing that's important
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of HubSpot
HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated well I
can see the client's whole history calls
support tickets emails and here's a test
from three days ago I totally missed
HubSpot grow better
last month I went to San Francisco for a
quick trip and I was only there for a
day or two and I met up with this guy
named Brett Adcock have I told you about
Brett dude have you stopped telling me
about Brett I feel like you've said have
I told you about Brett Adcock 16 times
on the show
have I
yeah bro you oh you love this guy uh he
started a flying car company took a
public Miss back and now he's building
robots all right well I I know this
story and we all know this story I went
to the robot Factory or whatever you
call it it's the robot Factory and it
sounds like a like a new age like a
Chinese food company or something like I
went to the robot Factory and I went and
checked it out it was amazing so he
basically in Sunnyvale he's got like
50 000 square feet and it's just 60
folks who worked there and I went and
talked to each person I was like what
did you do and they're like oh I helped
build the Cyber truck I helped uh build
this part of Tesla or I worked at Boston
Dynamics whatever like these like the
smartest of the smart guys and they're
building these machines and they're
basically they look like a Robocop kinda
and they're and these machines are like
they can walk around and grab stuff off
a shelf and pack like you know a t-shirt
or whatever into a box and I said didn't
he just start this how is it already
like how does he already have robots
that are working I feel like he just
started this like a like last year right
he just moved fast so basically uh the
recap is he started veteri which
eventually bought this company called
hired and so now it's called hired it's
like a recruiting company sold that for
100 million after he sold it he went
back to University of Florida and he
took classes in like he had already
studied like uh mechanical and
Engineering but he took classes in like
how to build planes I don't know what
that class would be called but classes
on that and he built this company called
Archer and Archer was uh it's basically
unmanned uh helicopters is like what it
looks like and they got a big contract
through United Airlines and they're
building these helicopters took it
public multi multiple billion dollars
then he took all of his money and when
he says all he says I basically I bought
a house in Palo Alto and then I have
like six months of savings and then the
rest I put all into figure which is the
new robot company and so he went and he
went and hired 60 people he financed it
and then eventually he just recently
raised a round of funding but for a
while he was just financing it and he
goes he goes I'm going all in he goes
you know our friend Ramon he goes all in
bro that's like his phrase he goes we go
all in bro and that's what Brett did and
so I'm walking around this Factory and
it's like these robots he's like check
this out we're working on the finger he
goes we studied like how the human body
works and like the way the tendons work
it like pulls in this direction so watch
this if you just pull the tendon here
and like your the finger like moves and
it's just crazy fascinating and I
started talking to him about it and he
and it's a really interesting business
model basically these robots can work
for 20 hours a day and he will build
them out or give them to like a Walmart
let's say and they'll pay the robot 30
of what they're paying a worker except
the robot can work now 20 hours a day
and then charges for four hours
super fascinating and I was like Brett
how big is this going to get he was like
well it's either gonna go bankrupt or
it'll be a trillion dollar company but I
think I'm going to build the biggest
company in the world and when I heard
just that audacity I was just like I
just got a little semi just talking to
him you know like I was just super into
it did you let out a small a small
female gas yeah like like if you would
have saw me standing up like my my heels
kind of like popped up you know it was
like like when you kissed a girl or she
said her heels like pops up
like what's that called by the way that
thing's amazing but what a thing that is
he just happened to have a fan there
that was blowing my hair it was it was a
romantic time you know we got romantic
real fast but it was really fascinating
because he actually said something that
kind of changed my perspective I was
like Brett
like software is way easier just like
why not do that he's like actually I
think software's harder when I was
building veteri we basically had to like
code stuff and invent stuff but with
physics and Hardware I'm just working
within the laws of physics and I know
that like what the laws are and if I can
get creative and create Solutions within
these laws I already know that people
are going to buy this thing so that
part's actually way easier to me than
you know like creating software where
it's basically a blank canvas and I can
make anything I want but this it has
really strict constraints and it kind of
like changed my opinion on things
they're super fascinating you have to go
down there and check it out yeah that
sounds pretty sick I'm surprised it's
that for a like ahead because I know
like Boston Dynamics and uh even Tesla
with its Tesla robot you know like
Boston MA has been going for like I
don't know 10 plus years
and they have like this weird dog robot
that can do parkour or something like
they have a crazy looking robot but
it's not like I don't I don't think it's
that functional yet like it's not like
replacing warehouse work yet uh in in a
real way well he explained that to me so
everyone knows Boston Dynamics you've
seen like viral videos of like or like
Bachmann like kicking like the deer that
look at that like the robot deer and it
like comes back at him he said that uh
Brett was I was like Brett who's your
competition Boston Dynamics and he's
like no because they are a research
company and so their DNA is not to build
stuff that people want to buy it's just
to push the envelope and it's almost
like a non-profit in a way I think now
it's owned by like Kia or Hyundai or
something like that uh so it eventually
will become more like capitalistic but
he's like they were just making stuff
and pushing the envelope and then
companies like us who want to build
stuff for commercial uses uh like
there's not that many use case or
there's not many other companies doing
something just like this and so that was
how we explained the difference between
Boston Dynamics and him there's a uh
video that's amazing that you should
watch it's the Amazon warehouse like
Amazon warehouse robots
and I don't know if you've seen this but
they're basically like they almost look
like you know back in the day in PE you
would get this like it's not a
skateboard because it's a square it's
like it's like a square version of a
skateboard that you can like sit on and
it's like a kneeboard I think they call
it yeah so all right
looks like that basically it's a flat
like square with four wheels on it and
I don't know if you've seen these videos
of the Amazon warehouse but there's
thousands of these and what they do is
they drive around so an order comes in
and they're like all right cool this
this person over here needs to pack an
order or they're packing the next 10
orders those 10 orders need these bins
so they go they drive they pick up they
go under the rack with the bins they
pick it up
and it's like like elevated like two
inches off the ground and then they
drive this huge rack of bins to the
human so the human doesn't have to move
they're sitting in their chair and they
just pick the items put them in a box
and then the robot takes it away and all
these robots they don't crash into each
other because they're all like synced to
one brain basically one brain is driving
all of them at once and so they never
bump into each other and they all just
go and they lift these huge racks and
bring them to the person because
otherwise if you've ever been to a
warehouse like normally it's like you
get a ticket you get an order and I've
done this I've packed thousands of
orders myself like you're like all right
I gotta go get something from bin 308
it's down in the far left corner then I
gotta walk to bin 102 because they
ordered these two items and then I'm
gonna try to do maybe two or three
orders however many I can you know carry
with my little uh tray here back to my
packing my packing station at the end
and then I'll pack all this orders and
so it's just so much faster just due to
these automations and you could
definitely tell how all kind of like
industrial and Manufacturing work is
going to get automated just it's just a
matter of what win and the companies
that do that are going to be very big
companies you uh recently bought a
Cadillac and Cadillac has really great
or they're supposed to have great
self-driving have you been using it no
you don't you don't use the stuff I
don't think ours even I don't think ours
even has anything like self-driving oh
really man I uh we just got a Tesla and
I before that I was using my friends
Tesla the self-driving stuff is awesome
man it totally has changed me and so
like I'm seeing like some of these like
now I'm a Believer before I was you know
kind of archaic I'm a Believer on a lot
of these things now I had to use it for
a week to actually understand I'm
shocked you don't have that though
yeah it didn't come with my car for
whatever reason but um yeah I had a
terrible Tesla experience but I don't
know I think I I rented like a
four-year-old Tesla so it just sucked
for whatever reason
well that's my very quick story on Brett
we have you have to go and see this guy
like it's so much cooler to see it just
feels so much more rewarding to work on
some of these products because a has
like a very real world application
and then also like you're it almost
feels like a bunch of friends just
sitting around and they're like oh my
God we just got the need to like kick
forward like you know it feels like a do
you remember um those TV shows when we
were kids where it was robot wars it was
like robots and that's basically what it
was it felt like that in real life where
they were just like tinkering on these
robots and like all right we have it set
up let's see if we can get the foot to
move and it just seemed so much more fun
than looking at a computer screen just
coding all day so it's really
fascinating you got to go down to his
warehouse and see it
yeah I look forward to three episodes
from now when you ask me have I ever
heard of Brett Adcock again it's gonna
be great yeah do you know I used to sell
hot dogs
[Laughter]
we uh we're supposed to tell you to go
there's a story behind all this let me
just quickly tell you you're supposed to
go to mfmpod.com
Webby Webby is
w-e-b-b-y-m-fm by the way there's not an
ad this is not an ad This Is War This Is
War there's a little small tiny war
going on and we need your help
so to be clear we don't care about the
webbies we got nominated for a wedding
what are the webbies
webbies is like an internet Oscars right
it's like an internet Grammys but it's
not basically that's a little bit much
because it's not like generous it's not
yeah that's what they're trying to be
all right that's what they're trying to
be that's generous
and so you can have a website a podcast
so if you go in the podcast In The Biz
is it the business category what
category are we their website's quite
challenging to work by the way like it's
hard to make work but yeah we're in the
we're in the business podcast category
but if you go to mfmpod.com Webby you're
going to get redirected to the right
link so the story of this is basically
HubSpot submitted rpod to this Webby
award normally this isn't something that
we would do because it costs money to
submit and I think there's even like a
dinner in New York which I don't really
want to go to but
here's the story there's this woman
named Kara Swisher Kara Swisher is this
popular journalist uh she started recode
I think it was called and she has got a
big podcast called pivot she's just like
an elite like kind of like who's who of
like our little Tech techie journal in
Silicon Valley she's super well known
for like I don't know 20 years 30 years
he knows how long she's been doing this
uh Sean would say she's kind of like
she's the Jake Paul of Journalism no no
no no Taylor Lorenz is the Jake Paul
with journalism I like I actually like
Harry so she's she's all right but I
agree by the way she came for us she
came for our neck she came for our neck
so but what happened was she tweeted out
I hate starting a story with she tweeted
out because I I immediately think of all
the mobster movies that like I just
watched this mobster movies of these
guys like killing each other and I'm
like
I'm starting a beef by saying like
she tweeted you know like it's like the
tweeted out like it's she said let's
just say she said here's what she said
to her face and what did she say did you
know what she said it was something like
she tweeted out a link to the webbies we
were we didn't even know where me and
you didn't even know we were up for
Webbie but there's like four podcasts
that are up for it one is her podcast
one is our podcast and she goes there's
no way uh something like this there's no
way I'm gonna lose we could like for
God's sakes like we can't lose to a
podcast called my first million ugh like
you know just like these Tech Bros these
money Bros and um you know what happened
the voting just swung even further in
our favor when she did that and uh and
Sam declared war instantly because Sam's
Sam's just literally walking around
looking for a fight I don't know if most
people know this like uh Sam's walking
around just hoping to get disrespected
just just to unleash a can of whoop ass
and so you tweeted back I mean you said
back to her face what did you say I
think I said uh
I think I said some I think she said
there's some podcast called my first
million that we're up against and
there's no way we're gonna lose or
something like that and I think I said
there's some lady who has a podcast that
just disrespected us or something like
that like you know if you listen to MFM
don't vote for us vote against this
snobbish elitism right of people who
love to smell her their own farts I
think that's what I said
and so that's where we're at there's a
war we went from 80 chance of Victory we
had 80 of the votes then she's came on
this campaign and uh and and said we
can't lose these guys it started it
started to go down a little bit I think
right now we're about to lose the Webby
and you know I don't want to win the
Webby
don't care about winning
but I definitely care about losing and
so I do not want to lose the Webby so
now we need your help go to mfmpod.com
Webby and uh yeah you know just just
right or wrong are you going to right or
wrong don't vote for us vote against
like people who think they're better
than you which is you know her and by
insulting us and if you're listening to
this she's insulting you indirectly and
so are you gonna take that what we're
gonna do is when we win Sean we're gonna
get like an award I think it's an award
I'm Gonna Keep It In The Box and I'm
gonna put it in a bigger box and I'm
gonna mail it to Vox which is who has
her podcast right like part of this we
don't we're we're not putting this Webby
up on our wall I'm not even gonna open
it putting this into her face so we will
mail this Webby to her because she
wanted it so badly and she will own the
Webby that says my first no hand on it
and what's gonna happen if they invite
us to the event to do this I am 100
gonna ask her to be my date my plus one
her plus one I would love it
and I can't go Sam's gonna take her if
that's how we're gonna do this if we're
allowed to have like plus ones I'm gonna
ask Kara if she'll be if she'll
accompany me and uh we'll hang out uh so
anyway do that uh mfmpod.com Webby
you'll go straight to the thing and you
guys will see it it's pretty funny uh I
think we had to take her to we had to
take her to Petty Court we didn't start
this war but we will finish it
um do you know this guy named Brian
Davis
sounds pretty generic name no I don't
know that name though he he's a he's a
Duke former Duke basketball player you
know in the 90s I think he was in the
90s oh okay yeah
um so something just happened and it's
pretty funny it happened this morning I
think and it hasn't played out yet but
it's actually it I think it's a a PR or
marketing stunt that might be hilarious
or it's a scam it's one of one of the
two but basically you know I'm not a
sports guy so so I might get a lot of
this wrong here but Dan Snyder owns
what's it called the Washington
commanders formerly the Chiefs right or
the Redskins uh yeah see I'm already
butchering it but basically I think he
has to sell it right or it's for sale
this guy named Brian David Brian Davis
he's a he's uh a black guy and so it was
in the news because it was saying this
guy offered to buy the the team and he
said I'm willing to give you a billion
dollars in cash in the next 24 hours and
then the next seven days I'll give you
the remaining six billion dollars and I
got proof of funds and all this and it's
a big deal because he's black and so
he'd be the first black owner but I
started doing some research on it it's
also a billion over so 6 billion is the
offer they had agreed to he came in over
the top said I'll give you seven billion
and and people like is he good for this
where is he gonna get seven billion
dollars he's like I'll give you a
billion dollars within 24 hours of the
deal being approved and then the rest in
seven days yeah so it's like a crazy
thing that he's saying and I started
doing some research on like his
background and so he has this company
called Urban Echo energy which is a
developer of renewable energy assets
basically uh you know remember like lead
lead certified buildings it was like
it's you're like green so I don't even
think he I don't know if he makes the
buildings or if he goes in there and
like contracts out and like determines
yes you guys are certified but his
company is called Urban Echo energy and
he said that uh uh he was telling people
when he was raising money for this
purchase that it's worth 50 billion
dollars
um and when I hear all these numbers you
know if you don't know anything about
business you hear this you're like wow
Brian you're killing it uh I think this
is 100 fake uh a complete like it's
either a scam or a marketing employee I
don't know which one it is this won't go
through but the fact that we're talking
about Brian Davis and there's like all
these articles going out there like how
cool is it that the you know this may be
the first black owned NFL team yada yada
it's all fake I think and it's happening
right now and so I'm very eager to see
how this unfolds but it's it's and so
I'm like was him and Christian Laettner
they uh they do a lot of real estate
like development in that like Durham
area I think they've been partners for a
long time
um
yeah so and he's I think he's had
multiple attempts to buy teams it looks
like so he's he tried to buy like a
soccer team for 33 million tried to buy
um the Memphis Grizzlies for 252 million
and so yeah I don't really understand
this but
but what I thought was funny it does not
smell right it doesn't smell like this
that they would have seven billion
dollars to to offer for this whether
it's their own or even the ability to
raise that much money but what I thought
was interesting and I started thinking
about this I'm like
what a brilliant marketing plan just to
make an offer that's just absolutely
ridiculous and it makes the news just
for being ridiculous could potentially
be a great way to get your name out
because now we're talking about this guy
he hasn't no no one's talked about this
guy in a while uh like I've said Kanye
running for president yeah it's like
this like the last time that I heard
about this guy I think was from that
like everyone hates Christian Laettner
documentary series
um but like no one talks about this guy
and I don't know what I'd be curious is
what goes in to making an offer for some
of these multi-billion dollar things
whether it's a company a sports team a
piece of art a house
and just can you just become that Troll
and just you make it in the news and you
start getting you start doing marketing
just as the guy who makes offers and I
just thought as a barrier to entry that
low on making an offer how does that
work
dude we could do it right now open up
Microsoft Word and let's tender an offer
for eight billion dollars
and uh let's see what happens Sam and
Sean have tendered an offer for eight
billion dollars
we're gonna send you 10 in cash now you
send two back that's how flush we are
so long as everything you know plays out
due diligence as long as we don't see
anything sketchy we're in right it's not
due diligence including us diligencing
our own finances when we find out we
don't have it then we're out well
because with Hampton I'm like all right
we need backlinks so we Rank and I'm
like what's a good way to get backlinks
fast and I saw this and I'm like wow all
these news sites are covering him
that's it I just found my strategy I
just have to make a ridiculous offer but
I thought this was hilarious that this
guy was actually like people were taking
it seriously on Twitter people like
people who aren't in the business World
we're taking it very seriously and he's
getting links from all these news sites
saying like NFL may have its first ever
black owner but they don't think like
wait a minute let's go
money coming from who is this guy right
yeah that's uh that's crazy I wanted to
talk about this thing that I noticed
happening and then I saw an article
that branded this in a really
interesting way did we talk about this
already the podcast Cafe do we already
talked about this you mentioned it once
what is it
so there's a there's this concept that I
heard that I liked but it's doesn't need
to sound as fancy as it is called kfabe
and it's basically like if you're did
you ever watch wrestling growing up like
like the rock and stone cold
yeah obviously there's only one answer
to that question yeah the stone cold
says so yeah of course so
in wrestling like the whole premise of
wrestling is that there's these like
manufactured storylines right so
manufactured alliances manufactured
rivalries beefs oh he he his manager and
he kissed his girlfriend and you know
that's why we need to fight right and so
the creation and and maintenance of
these storylines is called kfabe it's
basically like I don't know why I needed
its own
k-a-y-f-a-b-e and I don't know why I
needed its own word it's I also could
just be called like acting or story
lines but it's basically saying like
you know let's pull up the exact
definition but it's basically the fact
or Convention of presenting stage
performances as genuine or authentic so
it's basically take a stage performance
make it genuine authentic
this is happening all the time on Tick
Tock right now and I find it very very
interesting so if you go on Tick Tock
you'll often see somebody
like they're you it used to be this like
I'm holding up my phone I'm talking to
my phone and let's say I'm giving advice
I could say you know the thing you got
to do about blah blah blah okay that's
cool but how can we make that seem a
little more how can we make myself seem
more authoritative
well one thing people are doing is
they're buying this mic and they're just
putting it on their desk and then
they're looking to the side like they're
talking to someone else
and there's no podcast there's no others
there's no someone else there's no
podcast they simply bought a pie so
podcast microphone sales are going up
because people want on Tick Tock to look
like a thought leader it's like a
podcast
and the way that you make the Ted Talk
look legit you know so so why can I give
this advice or something so I saw these
two women doing this and it's like all a
joke though it's like women giving it's
like they call it the alpha female and
it's like you know apparently there was
this guy who was like look and he was
actually being serious he goes look if
you're 25 and you can't afford a
Lamborghini yet you're doing it wrong
and I think it's just ridiculous how
wrong you are if you can't uh you're
just lazy and so these two women now
have the alpha female and they're just
like giving horrible advice uh you know
back and forth and so many people have
been taking them seriously and it's 100
fake yeah this is this is exactly what's
going on and there's a whole bunch of
different versions of this so there's
um another popular thing you see on Tick
Tock is
somebody like just doing their kind of
morning routine or their night routine
like their skincare routine they're like
kind of brushing on makeup while they're
talking or they're like you know like
doing the like thing where they're
wiping off makeup and then they're like
washing their face while recording this
it's like oh so vulnerable girl next
door like you know so authentic just uh
it's like no she put the camera there
clicked record and then started doing
this to make it like look like I'm not
trying I'm just I'm just going through
my nightly routine I'm just talking off
top of my head here but it comes across
as not like somebody kind of marketing
to you or
um sort of like presenting to you but
like you're being let in and I find this
so fascinating that people are doing
this and you see this everywhere and
it's like the opposite of Instagram in a
way like
for Instagram
the The Meta of that was like go do the
thing where you rent the private jet for
30 minutes on the runway and take the
photos or like you know go hold the bag
and take the photo and then go return it
at Louboutin or whatever right like
people would fake status doing that and
then take talk they fake status
doing a completely different thing
sometimes it's like with this podcast
thing sometimes it's with like
pretending to be just doing their chores
and talking or whatever it is
and I find this really really really
interesting because it's like
it's effective
it's like low-key very like sneaky
what's going on and
um and it tells you a lot about how how
people work that this actually works you
know it like reveals a lot about
psychology that this that this actually
works so what's an example of one
uh well I just gave you two right like
that yeah give me another one example
um another one would be what so another
one would be like the podcaster ones
what are they saying are they giving
like money advice so one of the podcast
ones for example so yeah some of them
are business advice but one of them was
this girl promoting her only fan so what
she was doing was she goes viral because
she's on a podcast I think she says like
a face she gives a fake guess
she's a fake guest and she goes I you
know this whatever ear muffs for the
kids in the car if you're if you're
there but
um you know I make my man uh six times a
day once in the morning once and she
says this thing and then the comments go
nuts on Tick Tock like
like women hate it guys love it but the
comment section goes nuts because she
said this kind of outrageous thing and
somebody was like hey anybody got a link
to the full podcast maybe this was taken
out of context there is no full podcast
oh my God it's just this girl saying
something that's gonna get her a bunch
of like traffic on Tick Tock because
then you click her profile and you go to
her only fans and you subscribe and
that's all she was trying to do is
promote her only fans this way and I
thought wow like
this like five years ago I couldn't even
like if I told you the story like what
is Tick Tock uh why would anybody fake
being on a podcast being on a podcast is
like the dorkiest thing of all time and
what is only fans right like but this
person is probably making I don't know
50k a month on their only fans and well
this is their main marketing strategy
and that's like it's one of the things I
love and hate about marketing is that
marketing is this like never ending game
that's always changing there's always
like a new meta game to be playing and
the winners of it get really really rich
but it's also exhausting because you got
to kind of stay up on the latest thing
and uh and it also shows you when you
have a marketing thing that's working
like juice it because it's not going to
work for forever and uh the game will
the the game will shift so when you have
it working don't take that lightly dude
I remember as a kid growing up in
Missouri there was basically Zach Zach
was the cool guy in my class he was my
friend and he was cool because when we
were 14 you could kind of see that he
had abs and it was like oh man Zach's
got abs and Zach like cuts his hair cool
and he wears one of those like Puka
shell like necklaces that's cool oh he's
got vans on too like that's so sick
Zach's awesome I want to be like Zach
and then A step above that was like
Blink 182 it was like oh man play 22
like there's these guys in like Southern
California and all they do is skateboard
and Surf and eat corn dogs and play
music like how cool is that and I
remember being a kid and meeting
something inappropriate thing yeah
and they wear Hurley like what is Hurley
and I remember like it was basically
like three Inspirations of like it was
like Zach Blink 182 and like you know
Tony Hawk basically was like the people
who I thought were cool and uh I
remember even meeting someone I lived in
Missouri I met someone from California
I'd never been like at that time I never
basically been to Florida and Missouri I
met a guy from California and I'm like
do you know some 41 like are you friends
with them like how does that work like
you know I just thought that like this
was this other world and I would if they
if they were wearing Vans and like high
white socks I would like ask for a
picture if they had long hair I would
ask for a picture I'm like it's like I'm
meeting an alien like you are famous
just because you live in California
my fear is for my future kids them
growing up this like sphere of influence
has just gotten incredibly small because
instead of like the mediocre Zack of the
world there's now like I am now
comparing myself to the Thousand hot
kids who I'm flipping through on taking
the top point one percent Zacks of every
town of every town
yeah yeah there was a clear separation
of there's Zach and then there's Blink
182 and I can never be a Blink-182 but I
could probably be a Zach and that's
pretty cool now I just see all these hot
people on there they all can dance
they're all funny their teeth is perfect
in actuality they're probably the same
thing as like movies they're probably 25
year olds who like I think that they're
only 17. uh you know like how like you
would have like like Lindsay Lohan was
playing he's like dude you're like 26
and have fake boobs how are you going to
be playing the 16 year old you know what
I mean like it's like that same thing
and I and I'm like I've scrolled through
Tick Tock and I'm like if you're 16
right now this is the worst thing on
Earth because you are comparing yourself
to the point one percent of the whole
country not just like the Big Man on
Campus the one Big Man on Campus you
know who you kind of have a shot of
becoming dude that is so that is so true
that is so true that resonates so much
with me I had the same thing you know
sixth grade seventh grade whatever Casey
peruseman cool coolest kid on the
coolest kid I knew like if you said what
is the peak of what cool could be Casey
bruceman like uh you know he was cool
because he had the Nikes he french
kissed a girl once and I was like holy
[__] uh I remember going home and being
like wow I'm so far behind like the
world right now and that's how you know
but he was the cool kid he was he was
the only one to compare to you're right
like now if I go on Tick Tock I'm 35
years old now and if I go on tick tock
tick tock can make you feel very small
so can Instagram these these social
networks make you feel very small
because
oh you think you're funny
here's somebody being [__] hilarious
you think you're cute here's someone
gorgeous you think you're talented watch
this dance right like and that's swipe
swipe swipe better than me better than
me better than me better than me happier
than me more fulfilled than me richer
than me whatever it is right like
whatever your insecurity is the
algorithms like well I swiped it down
someone will just be like doing a selfie
I'm like wow look at their countertops
like that's a huge kitchen
[Music]
or like they'll be doing a thing in a
car and I'm like wait does that headrest
say Ferrari how is this guy you know
what I mean like it's just like it's
consumerism times a thousand of what we
were used to you know what I mean before
it was like every only if I went to the
mall I would see hot naked Abercrombie
dudes like wearing their like on the ads
now it's just like every single time and
it's the best of the best constantly and
it freaks me out
yeah exactly like you you could feel
like a you know tiny little uh compared
to this universe of awesome people doing
awesome things living these awesome
perfect lives and that's a
that's like a wmd for the for the ego
especially like a teenage ego like I
can't even imagine that yeah that's
that's pretty scary no I was thinking
about that because I've got friends that
have uh like 12 year olds and I'm like
and I and they'll like tell me stories
about how they're sad and [__] and I'm
like yeah I can see that this is
horrible this is absolutely horrible
because like before when I was a kid
there was just there was like if there's
like if Blink 182 was a 10 and I know I
could never become that but then Zach's
like the four and I'm a two so it's like
all right there I can close that Gap
maybe if I do enough sit-ups right now
it's just nine nine nine nine nine
everyone's a nine and I don't know how
anyone can compete with that and so I'm
freaked out about that a little bit
whenever I whenever I go through Tick
Tock I just you're better than me you're
better than me you're better than me
it's just it's constantly that they've
either renamed the for you page to the
better than you page yeah or just [__]
you
yeah
it's still Fu but now it's [__] you
laughs
oh that's amazing we should all right
that's it that's the end of the Pod
all right before we go ladies and
gentlemen we got a little celebration
and I say ladies and gentlemen because
I'm talking about the gentleman's
agreement and the ladies understanding
we have hit 200 000 subscribers on
YouTube
Sam and I promised that we would kiss
mouth to mouth at a million uh we do
intend to reneg on that as soon as it
happens but but if you want to see us
have to have to reneg on that agreement
we will we will do when we get there but
Sam 200k that's pretty awesome uh people
should go and do what to get us to 300K
yes the reason why it got to 200k
aside from us being good at this I think
is we started this at 110 120 I forget
and we came up with this thing called
The Gentleman's Agreement which
basically means all the content on
YouTube is free except there's one
channel which is the channel you're
watching right now it's not free and
it's called The Gentleman's Agreement
because we can't be there to make sure
that you pay your debt you just have to
do it if it's the ladies understand
ladies understand the gentleman's
agreement which means you now owe us
because this content is not free and the
way that you pay your debt is you have
to click subscribe on YouTube that's it
it's that easy we're working for you uh
but you you owe us and so you have to
pay your debt and just click subscribe
and that is the gentleman's agreement
the ladies understanding and so far it's
been very effective clearly everyone has
done it go to YouTube type in my first
million click subscribe turn on
notifications you know the Pod is much
better on YouTube you should just start
start listening to it oh and we have to
give out our premium we have I don't
know if you saw but last time we did
this people the last time we did this we
did a hilarious thing where we said use
the word premium in your comment and we
will give YouTube premium to one person
so let's do that now let's pull up uh
let's pull up somebody here and we will
give them YouTube premium
um right now I I think we should do this
every episode it's good which episode is
it it's gonna be a little costly but uh
but I think we gotta do it
um all right so I'm on the acquired one
I'm just gonna read you a couple of
these
this was a premium episode gents keep it
up
somebody goes um
this show had I don't know I must say
some premium insights guys great episode
uh somebody just kept spelling the word
premium over and over again
um simply premium content premium
episode even more premium guests keep it
up guys have a premium Easter I think we
got to give it to this guy who wished us
a premium
his name is famous hasta logo so I'm
gonna comment on here uh that he should
slide into our DMS we will pay for for
this guy's YouTube premium and in this
episode we'll do the same in the
comments whoever comes up with the
funniest use of Premium will get free
YouTube premium so you can listen ad
free and you can lock your phone and
listen to this in the background and
that's it that's the episode
[Music]
foreign